The one piece manga just showed the secret ruler
of the world government speaking for the very
first time. And with just a single word, we learn
that the ancient war between the world government
and the Ancient Kingdom might actually have been
an insane love triangle drama that changed the
entire world. At the center of all this is this
brand new character who was queen of Alabasta
at the end of the void century, and in this
chapter we get hints about her crazy ties to Imu,
Joy Boy, and even Amazon Lily. And you’re
not ready for the incredible theory about
characters from the void century that
we’ll discuss at the end of the video.
Starting with the former Queen of Alabasta,
Lily. Just like with the holy knights last week,
we are introduced to this character for the
very first time in this chapter, when Cobra,
the king of Alabasta – at least, before he was
assassinated – asks the Five Elders about the
past. He comments that the 20 swords jammed
into the ground before Imu’s throne belonged
to the original 20 kingdoms that founded the world
government. He then asks about Lily. Apparently,
she was queen at the end of the Void century,
making this only the fourth named character
who is absolutely confirmed to be from this
time period along with Joy Boy and Zunesha,
and one other we will discuss later on.
However, after the war, she disappeared
and was never seen again. Cobra mentions that
of the 20 swords, only 19 actually remain. And
he then even goes on to confront the Gorosei about
the will of D, about which the royal family has
passed down information through the centuries
and which seems to be connected to Lily and
the founding of the world government. Now where
did Lily go? Let’s see if we can figure it out.
First, you might remember that
at the end of the void century,
the twenty kingdoms defeated the Ancient Kingdom
and then formed the World Government. We first
learned in chapter 722 that the other nineteen
rulers went up to Mary Geoise and became the
Celestial Dragons, but Lily refused
to join them in the holy land. Now,
why did she do this? Well, there are a few
reasons that we are going to speculate.
The most likely reason is that somehow the
country of Alabasta was actually friends
with the Ancient Kingdom. We know this because
in chapter 202 it is confirmed that Alabasta
has been keeping a Poneglyph hidden from the
world government ever since the Void Century.
And now not just any kingdom can have these
stones. And that is because the poneglyphs
record the history of the Void Century and
other information that the Ancient Kingdom
did not want the World Government to erase.
And we see all throughout the story that the
poneglyphs were given to the allies of
the ancient kingdom all throughout the
world. These include Fishman Island, Zou,
Shandora, Wano, and apparently Alabasta.
And even though they have had
the poneglyph for over 800 years,
Cobra still fiercely protected the
secret, even willing to sacrifice
his own life to stop Crocodile from finding
it. So clearly it was important and probably
not just something they randomly found.
So how does this connect back to Lily?
Well, if Alabasta and Lily were friends with the
ancient Kingdom, then we have to ask how they
ended up being one of the twenty kingdoms
that defeated the ancient kingdom. Well,
while we don’t know for sure, it is possible that
someone from Alabasta, maybe even Lily herself,
betrayed the ancient kingdom, which helped the
twenty kingdoms to win the war. Maybe they killed
Joy Boy or somehow gave the twenty kingdoms
secret information. But whatever the reason,
it seems like the outcome caused
Lily to reject the other kingdoms,
and even her own kingdom,
to disappear into the world.
So with this in mind, let’s take a closer
look at who Lily actually could be,
what she might have done, and also the tangled
web of her relationships from the void century.
So get your popcorn ready everyone, because we’re
about to dive headfirst into a juicy love affair.
Starting with Lily and Joy Boy, who could very
easily have been in love with each other. Let
me explain. For the longest time in the story, we
knew that Joy Boy and Zunesha were from the Void
Century. And now that we know Lily was as well,
it makes sense that she would be connected to the
other two. Now that could mean the Alabasta was
friends with the ancient kingdom and Lily and Joy
Boy became friends this way. Or maybe Lily was
a pirate, since the ancient kingdom was likely
a kingdom of pirates, and then she only became
queen of Alabasta for a short time after the war.
But however they met, we know she gave
everything up for some reason after the
war. And what is the only thing that we know
for sure about the war. That the Ancient
Kingdom lost and Joy Boy couldn’t fulfill
his plans. *looks around nervously. Wait,
we do know this right?? Oda isn’t going to
trick us with this either, is he?? But it
makes a lot of sense to me that she was either
heartbroken that Joy Boy had died during the
war or that she was so ashamed of betraying him
that she decided to abandon her life as queen.
But then where did she go? Well, there is
one obvious place that would fit perfectly
with what we’ve explained so far. The
island of women, Amazon Lily. Now clearly,
both the character and the island share the name
Lily, and even in Japanese this word is written
the exact same way. Which by the way, did you
also know that in Japanese culture the lily
flower can represent purity, revenge, or even
a final goodbye for the dead, all depending on
its color. But in chapter 514 we learned that
Amazon Lily is a country of women only. Men are
not allowed on the island – except for Luffy now,
of course – and the warrior women will literally
kill any man who intrudes on their sacred island.
So, hmm, let’s see we have a heartbroken queen who
left her kingdom possibly after her lover was
killed. Kinda makes sense to me that she would
form a new kingdom where she would literally
never have to see another man ever again.
And even if Lily wasn’t in love with Joy Boy, it
could have been another man who broke her heart
or betrayed her, and there is one character in
particular who we’ll discuss in just a moment.
But back to Amazon Lily, there
is also the famous love sickness,
like we see with Boa Hancock, who is literally
dying because she has fallen in love with
Luffy ch 521-522]. And this sickness has
also affected other rulers of Amazon Lily,
so the deadly illness might have
started with Lily 800 years ago.
One Japanese theory I’ve seen is
actually so crazy I need to share
it with you quickly. Because it connects
Crocodile and Ivankov and Lily. You see,
some in the Japanese community have wondered
how Amazon Lily sustained their population
over time. We know that sometimes women
go out to get pregnant and then they come
home to have the children, but what if
the kingdom didn’t start out like that,
but they actually used the hormone fruit to change
people from men into women, just like we saw the
revolutionary army’s Ivankov do in impel down.
This would certainly lend more credibility to
the fun Crocodile was originally a woman theory,
that we have discussed on this channel before.
But anyways, with all this speculation about
the distant past, let’s bring this discussion
back to the present chapter. We get to
see Crocodile interact with the Gorosei,
and he asks them if they knew where Lily went.
The Gorosei reply that they do not – *coughs
liars – but if there is anyone in Mary Geoise
who does know about Lily, it would have to be
the secret ruler of the world, Imu. And ever since
they were first introduced we have believed that
Imu has been around since the void century. Why
is this??? Umm, well, I guess because they just
look like a 800 plus year old dude – or woman,
I mean we don’t even know if they are a man or
woman yet. But that is beside the point because
there are more hints that Imu knows about Lily.
And that’s because for the first
time, Imu makes an appearance and
FINALLY speaks. Of course it is only a single
world, but it is vitally important. They say
“Lily” right before the chapter ends.
And at this point my mind is going a
thousand different directions. Not only
are we introduced to a super important
character from the void century, but we also
learn that they seem to be important to Imu.
So just like we explored the possibilities with
Lily and Joy Boy, let’s discuss the potential
hateful, heartbreaking, and wholesome relationship
between Lily and Imu. And make sure to subscribe
to the channel because I promise not to break
your heart when it comes to one piece videos.
And just like with Joy Boy, it is possible
that Lily and Imu were in love. And there is
some evidence to support this. I mean just the
fact that the very first words we ever hear from
Imu is Lily’s name is pretty significant. Plus in
chapter 907, when we see Imu for the first time,
they have cut up a bunch of pictures
and bounty posters of Luffy, Blackbeard,
and Shirahoshi. However, the one picture that
they don’t destroy is Vivi’s. So this could
possibly mean that if Vivi is a descendant of
Lily, they share the same last name after all,
then maybe Imu really cares about or wants to meet
the long-time descendant of their former love.
And to take this idea a little further, if
Imu and Lily were in love, what if they had
a child and that child became the ruler of
Alabasta. So, I know it sounds crazy, but it
is possible that Vivi could be a descendant of
Imu and that is why Imu was holding her picture.
Plus, Lily and Vivi look shockingly similar,
so that’s one part this puzzle confirmed.
But if imu and Lily were lovers, then we have to
ask why would Lily leave after the war. Certainly,
Imu is still alive so if their relationship is
actually true, couldn’t they just have snuggled
up in that big castle. Well, something
would need to have changed during the end
of the war. Maybe – and this is where the
love triangle comes in – Lily was in love
with both Joy Boy and Imu, and when Imu the
twenty kingdoms defeated the ancient kingdom,
Lily was still so torn up about Joy
Boy’s defeat that she left anyway.
Or even if she was just in love with Imu,
maybe she was so disgusted by something
Imu did during the war that she didn’t
want anything to do with them ever again.
But that’s a lot of speculation about a
lover’s feud, so let’s reign things in a
bit and get to another possibility about Lily.
And this time, the former queen of Alabasta
is putting on that big pointy hat herself
[show Imu’s big hat/crown]. That’s right,
let’s discuss what could happen if Lily actually
became Imu. And let’s start by digging back into
Japanese culture. Because the water Lilies
are also an important symbol in Buddhism,
where they can represent both resurrection
AND enlightenment. So we have Lily who was
the former queen of Alabasta, and Imu, who
is possibly immortal and is “enlightened” as
the secret ruler of the world. By the way Imu in
reverse makes Umi, which means water in Japanese.
So if you haven’t yet connected the dots,
what if Lily was reborn as Imu when they
became the secret ruler of the world.
You can call me crazy, but it fits with
what we know about Imu AND with everything
else we’ve discussed so far in this video.
If Lily is Imu, she could still
have been in love with Joy Boy,
especially because she kept what we
assume is Joy Boy’s hat in this big
freezing vault. Plus Imu is kept secret
from basically the entire world and no
one seems to know what happened to Lily
after she left Alabasta after the War.
Wow, that is really starting to make a lot of
sense to me right now. But we’ll have one more
EVEN MORE INSANE theory for Lily at the end of
this video, but for now let’s look at this chapter
for the unfortunate king Cobra. Because while
Cobra is questioning the Gorosei, this is when Imu
shows up. And while we don’t know what happened
in this scene, somehow Cobra ends up dead. He
might have been killed by the Gorosei or maybe
the shock from seeing Imu led to Cobra’s death.
Either way, it leads to an even more
potentially world changing situation
because we know that Sabo crashed this secret
party a little later on. So we have to ask,
did Sabo see Imu? Because if he did, then the
world will never be the same because unlike Cobra,
Sabo got away. Surely Sabo will tell Dragon
about Imu and then there is no telling what
will happen. Will Dragon increase the
pressure on the world government? Will
he try to leak the information that there is
a secret world ruler to the rest of the world?
Truthfully, it is also possible that Sabo
didn’t see Imu, especially because it has
been about a month since this happened at the
reverie. And while Sabo was almost killed at
this island [show Lulusia], that attack was
not specifically meant to take him out, since
the Gorosei basically said they had already
planned to take out that kingdom. And honestly,
while it would be cool if the world
knew about Imu, I think it would also
be incredibly hyped if the straw hats were the
ones to uncover Imu’s secrets for themselves.
But with all of this talk about Lily and Imu,
this absolutely has to mean that Vivi is going
to be a super important character for the endgame
of the story. We know she is a descendant of Lily,
so it makes a lot of sense that she
would eventually learn all about her
ancient ancestor. Plus she is going to be
reunited with the straw hats very soon,
since she is on a blimp headed
toward Egghead Island right now.
And speaking of the end game, let’s discuss a few
final possibilities for what happened to Lily,
including a theory that could completely
change the final war of the story. First, Lily
could have simply been killed by the World
Government. That is definitely a possibility
here. Second, she could have been the one to
travel to Wano and have the poneglyphs made.
But speaking of Wano there is actually
one other named character that we know
about from the Void Century. In
chapter 964, we meet this woman,
Amatsuki Toki. And she would later go on
to become the wife of this chadly samurai,
she is actually born over 800 years ago in the
story. And that was only possible because she
ate the Time devil fruit, which allows the user
to send herself or others forward into the future.
And as we mentioned with Lily, Joy Boy, and
Zunesha, there is an incredibly high chance
that they would have known each other,
so it makes sense that Toki would have
been a part of that group as well. Especially
because she was specifically looking for Wano,
who was an ally of Joy Boy and the ancient
kingdom. But the important thing to consider
here are Toki’s powers. That’s right, at this
point I am wondering if Toki actually sent
Lily forward in time and that she is going
to be arriving very soon into the story.
And now, hold on, before you
get all angry about time travel
ruining the story, there are some actual
possibilities here that make some sense.
You see, remember that when Roger reached
Laugh Tale and learned the true history,
he knew that he was too early to really use
whatever he found on the island to change the
world. And while we have assumed that he was
waiting for Joy Boy to reappear – which has
now happened with Luffy – there could actually
be more to this prophecy. Because what if along
with Luffy’s awakening, someone else from
the Void Century was sent forward to help
the new Joy Boy not make the same mistakes
that the Ancient Kingdom did. Specifically,
I’m saying what if Lily was sent forward to help
Luffy in the fight against the world government.
And while we don’t know if she has any devil
fruit powers, we have learned in Egghead island
that the ancient kingdom had highly advanced
technology. So what if Lily if coming to help
the straw hats use some hidden technology,
or to counteract some hidden weapon that
the World Government has [show lasers that
destroyed Lulusia]. Or another possibility
is that Lily is the ancient weapon Uranus, and
she was sent forward to help win the final war.
And of course all of this is speculation,
and if Lily was sent forward that could
mean others from the Void Century could show up
as well, but I do think this is a possibility,
and one that could make for
an even more hyped final war.
And since we are talking about characters showing
up from the void century, here’s one more bonus
theory, inspired by reddit user Flidan. The
theory is basically about what if people from
the void century were turned into stone by the
Mero Mero no mi [show Boa using love beam] and
they are waiting to be revived for the
final war. And while the previous user of
the Mero Mero no mi definitely died and wouldn’t
be able to revive the statues themselves, it is
possible that there is some other way to revive
those statues, similar to what they do in the
anime Dr. Stone. Maybe there is some sake, like
Bink’s Sake that has been aging for 800 years,
and when it is finally ready it can be used
to revive the people from the void century.
But whatever happened to Lily, and whether we
will see her again, she is definitely a part
of the important information we absolutely have
to learn about the Void Century before the final
war. Because one thing we do know is that the
World Government won this battle 800 years ago,
and it is going to be a massive challenge for
the straw hats to take them down this time. And
if you want to learn all about the insane
new group of characters who could possibly
be the straw hats final opponents,
you can watch this video right here.
Shanks for watching.